all right let's talk about racist jimmy
kimmel you know jimmy kimmel of course
is the uh the host of the late night
show over there on abc and he has done
blackface and his former girlfriend
sarah silverman she's done blackface
these people love blackface i don't
really know jimmy kimmel uh it's not a
particularly funny guy he's completely
woke he bows to the to the mob
constantly like he knows that he is a
sinner right he's done blackface so he
knows he's a sinner so he always has to
go in on all of the woke bs that's sort
of the jimmy kimmel thing captured right
there i don't know anyone that's
watching these late night shows do you
guys watch these late night shows have
you ever actually that's kind of
interesting have you guys ever watched
like a late night comedy show
really just like watched a late night
maybe maybe a little bit maybe not
really that's interesting you're 29
you're 29 hell do you 26 so i got a 29
and 26 years they don't watch these late
night things nobody watches these late
night things anymore like this ain't
johnny carson's tonight show i remember
i think i was a senior in college i was
a senior in high school if i'm not
mistaken 92 maybe i was a junior in high
school i remember the last night of
johnny carson tonight show i stayed up
late stayed up till 11 30 at night i was
such a rebel back then to watch the last
night of the the johnny carson tonight
show anyway nobody cares about these
shows anymore if you're watching these
things and laughing there's something
wrong with you you should have your head
examined maybe that's what the
injections are for but anyway uh kimmel
was talking about kamala last night
she's the vice president that they
installed uh who's gonna take over for
joe when he steps down which good god
we're in a lot of trouble but anyway uh
she was talking about kamala and
basically if you don't like kamal it's
because you're a racist and a sexist
if anything can get the american people
fired up it's infrastructure so
and biden is alone americans really
aren't happy with this vice president
kamala harris kamala harris has an
approval rating of 28 which is
makes no sense because she basically has
nothing to do i mean it's like
[Music]
criticizing a backup quarterback tom
brady's okay
i don't love the way blaine gabbard has
his legs folded on the bench i have to
be honest
tomorrow's approval rating uh of 28 is
even lower in the 30 percent who
approved the dick cheney in 2008 after
he shot a guy in the face
i think these people are forgetting at
least 10 percent of the those polled
approved of dick cheney because he shot
a guy in the face
i think i know why kamala's ratings are
low besides sexism and racism which are
the obvious ones
it's because whenever she's next to joe
standing near him behind him she looks
like an assassin she looks like
nebula next to thanos ready to right
especially with a mask
hey kamala this guy's being a wise guy
show them what we do to wise guys
if you laughed at any of that
i don't want you watching this program
anymore okay we're banning you i don't
know how we can do that do we have that
kind of technology yet okay we have
something i got a thumbs up over there
uh you can't watch this program anymore
that's it
now think about there's probably 20
writers on that show they've probably
got to staff about 100 people
20 writers sat there to write that
drivel where he also called most of us
racist and sexist now if her approval
rating is 28 that means her disapproval
rating is about 72 percent that means
he's calling 72 percent of americans
racist and sexist now my disapproval of
kamala harris has absolutely nothing to
do with her sex or her race it happens
to do with the fact that she is at
nothing what do you think kamala harris
really believes nobody really knows
right she's incredibly disingenuous she
comes off as deeply inauthentic i don't
know what she really stands for i
remember that video who it was about
this time last year when she was
pretending that when she grew up as a
kid she celebrated kwanzaa like the
woman is just a deeply
authentic liar she was polling at zero
she was polling at zero percent in the
democratic primary when she dropped out
zero percent within her own pri party
primary and then eventually when the
machine chose biden as the victor they
then chose her as the backup someone
polling at zero percent i mean that's
almost impossible to to poll at zero
percent when there's only about 12
people right uh and the media loved her
from the beginning it may be hard for
some of you to remember this but when
the democratic primary was originally
happening
people thought at that first debate
people were like oh she's the
frontrunner and then she left after a
couple weeks again zero percent not one
percent like one percent of the people
like you that's pretty depressing zero
percent of the people like you so so
we're on to something here this dislike
of this woman but then i thought no it
must go deeper it can't just be the
inauthenticness it can't just be that we
don't really know what she stands for it
can't be that she jailed a whole bunch
of people uh when she was attorney
general in california it can't just be
like all that stuff there must be
something else about it and then i
thought wait a minute there is something
else
[Applause]
[Laughter]
she should be the joker in the next
batman movie that would make more sense
to being vice president but nobody is
sexist or racist because they don't like
her jimmy kimmel you are a racist you
are in blackface he used to do an
impression of carl malone uh the nba
player on the utah jazz and uh he'd be
in full but not only blackface full body
full black body that's a thing and uh
and he'd be also making fun of the way
karl malone spoke and whatever so jimmy
is just terrible you're just a terrible
human being jimmy kimmel uh and kamala
harris
lordy lordy lordy